yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby
let's go baby look at us couple Golden
Goose tle Golden Goose couple silly
golden gooses yeah we're wearing very
expensive uh designer sneakers everybody
they got a zipper on the side uh and
they're hand come broken and handmade
they're French I think they're French or
they're Italian they're one or the other
I'm pretty sure look up if Golden Goose
is French or Italian I'm going to say
Italian I think French yeah France it
feels like it would be
French um from
France Italian Italian yeah oh business
founded in by husband and wife Alexandro
gallo and Francesca Ronaldo Italian
interesting yeah yeah French don't make
a ton of shoes that makes sense yeah
French Italians make perfume cheese
theage uh how was how was a fight
companion yeah Joey Diaz how's Joey Diaz
doing he's great he's in Jersey loving
life out there yep
semi-retired yes I mean he's he agreed
with Rogan on the show and at dinner
that where he'll come down like three
days um every month at the Mother Ship
really and ran was trying to give him to
move he's like it's not happening he he
I love Jersey my daughter's there I've
been to his house in Jersey is nice yeah
he just loves it up there he's like it's
not happening no he's like I can come
down do my thing but I'm not moving down
he's like it's not happening no and then
Rog is like all right well let's just
get you down here and we'll go from
there y yeah he's like he's like you got
to warm me up he's like you're trying to
go all the way with me on the first date
you got to warm me up let me just feel
it out let me feel it out let me see
what's up but yeah i't seen Joe in a hot
second it's so good to see him ah it's
great Eddie was his usual awesome self
the best all that and I heard you guys
had a little talk about me fighting
Andrew Schultz I don't even know how
they got brought up yeah I think Eddie
brought it up me and Eddie sided with
you of course and then Rogan was saying
Schultz and because you have SE hit MS
would I I didn't think it helped the
case for Andrew schz when they showed
the M thing no Andrew's a good it was
like the Floyd thing you know where
they're like the M the B guys touching
the gloves yeah um and Rogan's case was
like you know his level of discipline to
get to Arena act If You Can level of
discipline he's more disciplined than me
thinks uh I just think I think the the
way like he's just saying like the the
tenacity and like the work ethic to get
to Arena act like that see but I don't
think that translates to fighting no no
I didn't want to keep the conversation
going I was like all right Brian beat
the [__] out I don't want to keep going
with it but then I want to be like can
you know like Elon Musk and Zuckerberg
have insane work ethics doesn't mean
they can fight yeah like I got to see a
guy get punched in the face I've seen
you get punched in the face before and
you don't back down no and I love
Schultz Schultz is one of my favorite
well I was thinking I like I likew so
much I would never look forward to
actually fighting I don't think about
that at my age you guys aren't going to
hurt each other neither one can fight
but you guys you guys can you can hurt
each other I can hurt somebody if I
punch him in face I think if it's spar
with head gear on nobody's going to get
hurt guys do it guys are doing it right
now but I've hit people when they're
they have headgear and hurt them you
guys AR going to hurt each other with
head gear on you you guys could Spar and
you be fine I'm sorry you think hold on
you think you can't Spar Andrew Schultz
without hurting him I've people no I'm
saying but I've heard might get
concussed but you think you're going to
like change the DNA Spa I'm saying I'm
saying you can hurt people very I've
heard people very easily when they're
wearing head gar cuz I punch I can punch
hard enough to hurt you I mean I don't
understand no you're taking it personal
no no I'm not talking person I've
sparred B I've sparred hold on so many
rounds Bubba yeah everyone's fine if you
in Schultz spar right nobody's getting
knocked
unconscious um it's not happening why
why do you say that how many guys have
you knocked unconscious sparring um I
well I don't n none none yeah no and you
guys are friend yeah we're we're not
going to no one get knocked out flat
right of course not you guys would do a
friendly thing of course of course and
even if you guys want to it's tough to
knock somebody out dude it's [__]
tough you're also 56 Schultz is 40
something nobody's getting knocked out
now if we include spin but I was like
hold up Brank and kick no it's just
boxing you guys could do it and be a
friendly thing yeah nobody's going to
get hurt yeah now if you guys would do
it like on the street then it's like
Jesus Christ exactly that's what I'm
saying but I'm talking about 60 o gloves
head gear nobody's getting knocked out
right you guys could do that yeah I
think so do it all the time I used to do
it all the time it was fun get to a
point with sparring where where we would
we would do this round robin at the gym
and like like you can it's it actually
gets to be fun because you learn how to
protect yourself you learn how to you
know keep your heads and hands yeah no
one's getting starched left and also
nobody's trying to kill each other even
if they are it's [__] tough dude to
knock a guy out it's tough man well yeah
especially with he yeah now if you're
now now if I'm fighting a guy who's good
it's pretty easy for them knock you out
I mean if if you're fighting a good
boxer and you've and you're in there and
you're a guy who boxed the way I did
they can knock you out they can hurt
you're talking about a professional uh
or just even a good good amateur of
course but that's what they do but why
are you doing that no yeah we're well
when you move around with a really good
guy in the gym they're not doing that to
you no they they could not get guess if
you want to be a dick but you and
Schultz aren't doing that neither one's
a professional far from it you guys
would be fine like if three round three
minute thing nobody's getting knocked
out I also if I may I think I'm very
disciplined when it comes stand up
because I write all the time so my
standup is great now my promotion I'm I
have a mental block to it I'm not great
about that you're 56 name one someone 56
who crutched that promotion that's not a
thing I I don't think came up in a
different thing I think um yeah I just
like how my discipline wouldn't be the
same as like if I think he said I think
he had that like he has a block when it
comes you with that but I think because
when you got into it you're also acting
when when you know other guys are going
full comedy you're doing it all yeah
there's nothing wrong with that yeah it
also worked out you had your own
freaking sitcom yeah discipline's never
been my problem I I that that's that's
never been an issue hard work and
discipline is never it's it's just maybe
not as focused more scattered doing a TV
show yeah that that took doing a podcast
TV show and the road that's a lot it's a
lot your instead of just doing and used
to always say just focus on stand up and
and podcasting and I didn't I I had a TV
show I had two TV shows a big deal yeah
no no shame that was my goal that was
always what I wanted to be so when's the
fight that's a good question because
I'll start training if I have to the shy
doing it no but either you don't see me
doing it Bubba I'm 57 soon and I have
four kids I'm going on four kids I wish
I had the time yeah do do I go to a gym
and train in two hours a day that's
going to be tough dude it be fun I don't
see it happen unless I'm getting money
for it yeah I yeah I don't think we impa
shty enough either yeah sold out Mass
Square Garden I don't think he's now
yeah that's a yeah and also I have to
say boxing like Jiu-Jitsu is one thing
boxing like if you said Brian you're GNA
fight Mark
Wahlberg I'm I'm training four hours a
day and I'm gonna take what's a big
payday well I'm also gonna I also I'm
also I don't want to and there's nothing
I'm I don't want to lose to that guy in
any context so I'm going to take it way
too seriously with Schultz he's younger
he's athletic I don't care and he been
boxing yeah I haven't box while but I'm
saying he beat me or he I don't care
like it's great it'd be fun to do
because I I like the guy and he's young
I don't see anyone pausing their life
for years yeah but if I'm if you say bro
you're gonna go fight Mark Wahlberg or
something I'm gonna go let's see is he
he's there with uh banovski no this is
that's the one that he that ran showed
yeah okay Joe all right Joe
yeah yeah did you watch the fights on
Saturday I did not watch the fights I
only watched the first uh yeah okay well
that's not boxing though right that's
not boxing I mean it's h mid but again
when Rogan brought up I was like I
wasn't like OHF you're with it's just
not boxing though B that's that's that's
I he hitting Ms yeah yeah it's just okay
you know you guys AR neither way are you
going to do [__] yeah well right it's
fun to talk about though it's not
happening I love both you guys I do it I
don't think schy would do it I don't no
there's nothing he's not he's not a
boxer he doesn't he doesn't he's never
boxed I also don't think he cares he's
also not been in a ring or done anything
yeah yeah but he's so fun but he's great
yeah I I wouldn't be boxing either Rob
Andrew did you uh did you were you able
to watch the fights on Saturday I
watched uh Neil magney win that was
awesome then I had run on stage right
yeah that was amazing but his cardio
that guy that guy gassed and that was
really interesting but that kid looks
like an athlete I saw the first I saw
the first round and I was loving I was
loving Strickland's jab he was putting
it on him and he he looked fast he was
kicking definitely won the first yep uh
but I did not see it after that I'm
going to watch it yeah what' you think I
thought nobody got robbed I thought
Strickland won give him the first round
fifth round clearly and then you can
give them two or three you pick probably
probably two you know yeah but no one it
happens you know it happens I didn't
think I I thought Strickland for
whatever reason something seemed
different with him I'd like to hear from
Nick zck with the mentality but even
Nick sick in the corner was like let's
go let's get going here because he never
did the Shan Strickland where he kind of
just he's this constant wave and it
takes over so it just didn't click now
it could be DDP so awkward and good
where he didn't feel like he had the
opportunity to do that so there could be
that but and DDP is a rugged son of a
[__] huh tough hell yeah yes took some
took some took some Bea I saw the
Pennington fight actually I saw that
worst TI fight of all time it was uh not
her fault you know I think it's more of
wayo Silva's issue but well well Raquel
kept clinching and her her Corner kept
saying just keep banging make distance
and bang and kept clch what's that okay
um yeah I thought it was more heard it
was just a bad fight it's all it's all
good I heard the mozar uh evolv is a
beast on on Arnold Allen Arnold Allen
had great takedown defense yeah but yeah
the whole card was you didn't miss much
I didn't right how's our boy is Mark
Andre buo is that the guy who you like
the special forces guy absolutely Ben no
we would have talked about what's his
name Ben was St Den he's fighting doen
por that's the guy I want to that's
that's that's UFC 299 okay you got to
watch that main event so we can chat so
I hung with I hung with at my show uh K
Kelvin gastam and uh the great Henry
cejudo showed up one of the goats love
them yep and then with a bunch of uh
with this Helen moroles who was a gold
medalist in the Olympics at wrestling
and a an absolute smoke show God if she
gets into a smoke show MMA she's GNA
take it over she's yeah gorgeous and
pretty and the gold medals a and then
this girl Victoria Anthony another all
my friends were like she's gorgeous and
and then she play fights at 105 but um
but also just cool as [__] it was great
to have them in the crowd and then they
came back to the green room with those
animals with seudo with gasoline and the
rest of their their uh wrestling crew
who got downright Rowdy when the tequila
started flowing
Rowdy that was that was that was
Insanity right there and cejudo's fight
is is he at two is he 299 cejudo no cuz
Sean Sean sugar Shan who I did his
podcast I went and did Tim Welch and
sugar Sean's podcast the best they're
set their gym looks so good his is 298
in February that should right with the
Morad yeah I talked to I talked to Henry
about that I was like dude you got
nothing to prove you got nothing to
prove you did it all and he goes I know
but I can't I want to go out on top yeah
he just you know he can't help it he's
just comp fight Mor Rob's a maniac yeah
now let's see if Mor Rob's wrestling
works on a guy like cejudo that's a good
question be let's take a little break
pal I need something to calm me down
maybe just help me sleep sometimes maybe
just take the edge off you know cuz I'm
intense as [__] I do a lot of sports and
stuff stand up I fight you might be
pitching MLB who knows you never know I
you know I recently got a concussion
flipping my truck so that's cool yeah
and one thing that helps with that is
CBD CBD do I get where do I get CBD like
where do I get something that's fully
legal ships to all 50 states where do I
get something that's third party lab
tested how do where do I get something
that's up to six times stronger than our
competitors and grown in the USA that's
important dude you can get it for free
by visiting five fi cbd.com fighter it's
helped me out and I've been taking The
Daily Buzz sour they CBD and THC in a
potent 5 to1 ratio yes sir they
definitely do you know you're getting
the very best it's us hemp Authority
certified so you know it's good go to 5
CBD spell out 5 cbd.com figher and you
get your $40 bottle for free during the
month of January just pay shipping and
handling that's how confident they are
that you love five Daily Buzz gummies
they're just give them away that's 5
cbd.com fighter f icbd /
fighter I think sleep is probably the
most important thing you can do for your
health why do you think in Navy Seals
Bud Camp they sleep deprive those guys
because you need sleep I need sleep I
need good quality sleep if I if Dad
didn't get sleep oh nightmare heavy
you're weak you can't do anything I just
wish there was something out there that
could help me well you know a recent
study found that not getting consistent
good sleep can increase your risk of
heart attack weight gain depression
muscle deterioration
okay yeah but what do you have something
I can take to help me sleep look listen
you could take melatonin you could take
wine take
alanine but I'll tell you this right now
what you want to do is go to Native path
collagen PM okay what yeah because each
serving includes your classic SE sleep
supplement you got melatonin you got
Gaba you got magnesium you get eleanine
all of them are proven to help you sleep
faster improve sleep quality and reduce
stress disturbances like racing thoughts
which is what I suffer from oh I wake up
and I'm
like hey is everything wrong You're darn
right and right now it's also got 10
grams of grass-fed collagen which can
support Muscle Recovery and Joint repair
while you sleep yep and right now
they're running a limited time promotion
where you can try all three of their
flavors native path collagen PM
completely free they just have ask that
you cover shipping that's insane deal
for these these powerful sleep muscle
and joint ingredients so don't miss out
on trying this free today to claim your
free collagen PM variety pack today
simply visit get nativepath
docomomo your sleep we'll see I don't
know but but morab and and Sterling
similar you know as far as they train
together train Partners right Sterling
took down I didn't realize this you know
how many times Sterling took seudo down
four oh yeah crazy yeah right I mean
yeah is monster monster Mor's monster
too gas tanks
nsos not so well you know like like
everyone else I think Henry is is a sick
competitor and tougher than just amazing
you know he's how old is Henry Cudo now
you know you get it's it's it's probably
it's just there is there is that thing
36 36 and at at at 135 36 that's
different yes and that's a there's a lot
lot of miles on that guy but look at
guys title fights over 34 their success
is not good this a title fight but I'm
saying in general after 34 it gets dicey
yeah that's just father time and with
the smaller weights especially 36 just
because of speed endurance all that
stuff everything yeah and yeah but if
anyone's getting pulled off it's gonna
be cejudo so good our boy our boy sharan
is uh they they had this great gym out
in
Poria and uh like Tim welson the guys
just built that place up I mean it's
just unbelievable but sugar is his his
confidence is Skyhigh he's one of those
dudes who just shows up he just [__]
shows up the podcast we did drops today
and his his [__] just shows up look at
him what do you mean shows up uh he just
on on fight day I was talking I was
asking him about his mindset and he goes
I'm just so calm on fight day it's when
I'm doing it that's what he's meant to
do yeah that's why he's World Champ yeah
he's just like that's when I come you
know that's when I'm ready yeah he's one
of those guy it's like we're not talking
about practice no we're not talking
practi when that's why champ yep yep
yeah you go yeah you gotta watch that
main event so we can chat about it I'd
like to your thoughts on it I will yeah
I will because uh I heard I heard it was
me and Rogan and Dana gave it to
Strickland wow that's a lot yeah but
nobody got robbed you can see how they
how how the judges would I'm surprised
though because the Strickland's the
champ so you have to take that belt from
what world well I mean Dana says that
Dana goes I was say you got to take it
from the champ but that's not the way
the judge that's not how the judges so
when everybody says that it doesn't make
sense do the judges that's like saying
in the in in NFL like man touchdowns
should count as eight points like but
they don't they're seven yeah yeah but
should be eight okay no no no but I mean
typically though you do see when when a
champion like you could make the case
that in most title fights if the
champion isn't beat decisively a lot of
times they get they get not really it's
not the way scoring works it's just not
the way the game works but people do you
typically they
for whatever reason I think you get
there's something about holding the belt
that they the favor the nod usually goes
in in a fight that close the nod usually
goes to the champ not really if you look
at it's just not the way you look at the
stats it's just not not the way the game
works didn't Strickland land more yeah
it's weird but he got taken down a bunch
got taken down six times but the
takedowns meant nothing yeah like the
takedown and then the the counter of the
takedown is getting back up so if you do
nothing with takedowns they don't really
count them rematch no I don't I don't
think I I think uh H's at UFC 300 or uh
Izzy Could Happen okay
although yeah head 90 that's a
lot well just means no that's 90% of the
strike were to the head oh okay I got
you but then if you look at the compy
strike numbers you can't always go off
compy strike CU taked downs and ring
agress and stuff like that but um it's a
close fight it looks like it was a
really close fight
I can't wait to watch it go go to ESPN's
Instagram I think it's ESPN MMA they
posted a whole thing on it you look at
that you're like God dang I I had
Strickland win again not upset that DDP
won I can see rounds two through four
you'd give him then one and five you
give to Strickland I think you could
definitely find a round for Strickland
between two and four definitely not four
but two or three you could nod his way
yep look at that new one yeah that
one wow that's hard to argue with so you
I I I give him round uh 1 three and
five five that's confusing then a little
bit it's got to be a bummer for Sean and
then go over to Dana White's comments
Jen here you
go fight did you have on the school
funny I we were just looking at the at
how the media is SC and uh right down
the middle I had it uh two to two going
into the last round same and I thought
stri won the last round um
guys were sitting at the same table had
it the other
way uh you know it was a close fight
it's a good fight it's a good fight I
mean that's that you know you lose you
lose you win you win I mean that's what
it is yeah I look at his his eye though
look at uh dup's eye damn poor duplic
eye because I I do like dupes and you
know he's earned every every bit of this
yeah and then they're he's doing the
media thing you know and he goes wait
you can see you know he's he hasn't been
on social media thing he goes wait wait
people think I lost that fight and the
journalist goes yeah he goes like who
and he goes Dana White he goes [__]
you're just like ah poor I know how that
feels yeah like come on don't take his
wind where you hear Dana's upset and you
know you're just screwed you're like oh
no cuz if Dana says that and Rogan says
that on their platforms the two most
famous guys in the world soon as they
coign that the other gu everybody jumps
on that then it's this whole all the
Sheep go and then it's just the police
is like oh my God yeah where there's an
argument he won the [__] fight of
course but when Dana and R go n i got
this guy you're like oh no and I did too
it's got the belt it's got the belt yeah
it doesn't matter for him he'll be an
underdog yeah think about that
accomplishment it's big deal right nuts
nuts like like I was looking at Shan Ali
and I was just like you're a champion
insane and and went through Killers you
know I mean you know as far as Peter Jan
yeah yeah Peter Jan and then he beat
Sterling ALG Sterling
yeah like what um who is who is duplic
gonna fight next so if I'm if I'm
comot you know hot's down we don't know
where Izzy's at you he he said I'm down
for 300 if I'm dupes dude I'm not
rushing back in there I'm I'm enjoying
the fruits of my labor I'm doing the
whole media thing getting my brand up
getting more famous and then fighting
about 6 to8 months okay that's what I'm
doing can you do that d you're the champ
what are you going to do you're the
champ that's what you should do any guy
that rushes back in how's it paid off
aljo rush back in against sugar which he
didn't want to they've rushed guys in uh
Izzy uh rushing in and then fighting
strictly on short notice losing the belt
I'm not I'm like no no no I don't feel
good I'm going to wait I would soak it
in get all the accolations all the
accolades all that do all the Press get
my name up even bigger and then fight in
6 months cuz he fights at 300 and the
it's not knock on DP I know it sounds
like I love he's a monster he's being an
underdog no matter who they pair him
with next if he fights strickling again
he'll be an underdog if he fights Izzy
again he'll be an underdog not I'm sorry
if he fights Strickland again he'll
probably be a slight Underdog he fights
Izzy he'll be an underdog Hamot to be an
underdog Bo nickel Underdog even Bo
nickel oh yeah so there's nobody he they
can offer's wrestling yeah there's
nobody they can offer him where he's
going to be a favorite so so the the
odds are you're probably going to lose
that fight dude take in take it in
it's so hard to get the belt and these
guys can't enjoy UFC is rushing them
back in they're going to rush them back
in dude the UFC is going to do what the
you think the UFC cares if dup's brand
gets bigger no they care about no they
care about UFC 300 right 300 I some
people care about it if I'm do polies
I'm not bending over backwards to please
the UFC and make 300 [__] them n dude do
your thing do what's best for you and
your family get your brand bigger go on
all the shows America now you're the
champ so ESPN's going to have you on all
this more sponsor
you fight in what what in June so you
got February March April May then June
oh when it's April so you got February
March April April 13 April so you got
you got three months no is he are they
telling him to figh in three months ask
him if he's down no so so on you have
three months now you're going to be
suspended for price you need a two two
month fight Camp well right so you we
camp so you have a month off to what and
then heal then go straight back in Camp
it's not ideal took a beating five five
rounds
yeah there's no upside and for what to
please the people so you make 300 [__]
no dude go do the whole media tour take
your time tell him six months don't talk
to me for six months what kind of money
you think that they made for this fight
he was in champ so I I don't know he
he's probably you know low six figures
yeah low low six figures low fig yeah
that ain't GNA that ain't going to get
it done you go to you got to figure out
a way to make as much money as you can I
I would sign all my endorsement deals
now do a year to two-year deal yeah
because as the champ you're you lock
them into a year deal so there's there's
no Clause that says if you don't if
you're not champ you make less money
lock in the money now for a year to two
years yep take six months get all these
endorsements as the champ and then fight
dude get your brand up bigger then fight
don't rush back to please the fan base
in the in the media in the UFC to save
300 correct [__] you correct take your
time bud 100% I made
592 uh no strictly made 592 he made 532
not bad now it's not great that's
estimated yeah but he made so Strickland
made 592 plus pay-per-views which
probably not going to be that high so
Strickland's made good money but for DDP
you know 532 plus sponsor so he can
chill for for you know 6 months yeah I
would assume of course that would be the
smart thing to do right I me build the
brand lock in endorsements to year
twoyear deals with a no Champion clause
in there lock in all the guaranteed
money dude right now his team should be
working overtime right now overtime yeah
cuz now he's the thing right I hope I
hope he listens to they won't they won't
no well he seems to be a smarter one cuz
remember they tried to rush him in there
to fight Izzy when he was hurt right in
Australia and he went no and the UFC
shunned him for it and were mean nasty
about it and then they put in Strickland
that's how stricken became champ how
does Izzy and DDP how how does that work
out do you think what what is your
thought tough fight for DDP tough fight
for DDP because he's got a strike with
somebody like Izzy who's longer and I
think he has better takedown defense
than strip St yes much tougher take
Downs more traps more calculated if it's
Izzy and he's on not like the Strickland
fight it's it's a tough fight man it's a
tough fight for for I'm DDP I look at
the landscape don't rush back in it and
lose the belt dude you're going to be an
underdog lock in all these endorsements
go on the media tour get your name
bigger then fight com out was sick last
I saw he posted UFC he wants UFC he
wants DDP at 300 Ham's asking for it
even though ramadan's there posted he
was sick post a picture of him training
with the number 300 on it he wants DDP
at 300 that's a big fight damn I'm those
fights but if I'm DP those fights aren't
going anywhere dude [__] 300 don't rush
back into be the savior because you're
going to lose your belt and I'm not
saying he's for sure going to lose his
belt but the odds are it's say after
three months is not enough you don't
need to fight so quickly you've taken
all that damage and and uh don't be
tougher than don't be T too tough for
your own good yeah and I'll take don't
be a company man name one person that's
worked out for Chrisman ABAB when he
cut8 60 lb and I don't know three days
did they give him bonus no who else it's
worked out for let's think about that
Donald Cerrone look at how long GSP took
a long time between fights right all
those guys did they hate
that um UFC hates it do what's best for
you Conor said already he's different no
I know that's that's a bad example but
um you're right I mean but being a
company man who's it worked out you're
doing what's good for the machine for
what's good for you and the career so
short especially at champ take your time
dude you're champ you call the shots now
now if he's now you don't want to be
ridiculous like I'm gonna take a year
off then they're they're going to do
earn interm Bel joh Jones took a takes a
long times now part of that's speak
different different CU you're talking
about goat it's different but even if
you're Champion you have some power now
dude yeah spider took a long time didn't
he you're talk but this is different be
Anderson John GSP you're talking about
different
Str CH you're talking about goat what
about
volkanovski he takes time yes no I mean
he's rushing back now he got knocked out
by Mev now well that's CU he lost but
like I'm saying he knocked out he's
still champ yeah he also got knocked
down at 55 so that's a different he's
back down to 45 and but still you got
knocked out you're rushing back in not a
good idea defend your title and for what
to save what dude right cuz UFC's saying
oh we need you here [__]
you yeah man UFC keeps going The Fighter
your career is so short especially as a
champion it's the toughest thing in the
world heavy lies the crown and he got
knocked out in a short notice fight too
that's what I'm saying that's that's
yeah that's not a good idea there's no
rush I don't get the rush they're trying
to the to get back in there Fighters
they're like I can fight anybody anytime
it's that mentality right yeah that's
why you have good managers
yeah so I hope he enjoys the fruits of
his labor and doesn't Rush In And feel
like he has to save 300
yeah we'll say see yeah we'll see we
will see Fighter's going to fight
Fighter's going to fight Fighter's going
to fight um I don't know if you know but
I I was scouted by the major leagues oh
were you yeah so I'm everybody should
know that my hand eye coordination isck
what's the word off the charts um I
stood at the plate while Major League
Dominican baseball players in the major
leagues were
throwing past me and Dominicans can
throw uh they can throw they are all
awesomely they're all like six4 just
those now now now I was out there with a
bunch of guys some big Leaguers who are
pitchers and with all due respect to
Pitchers you'll see some pitchers that
don't look like they've done much um
they they don't look like they've done
much sport sporting bubble they look
like they walked out of a bar some of
those guys they're just giant guys do
this watch this get on the ball trying
to get my eyes it's all from here it's
all from here and this area
the hardest I know he threw he throw so
hard that
guy 98 this this is so get in the Box
Pedro I that's a p here I am look at my
now I'm not a pitcher
guys oh I couldn't believe
it dude now he wasn't throwing his heat
but he was
an 80 88 mph change up I can't believe I
got my bat around in time can I tell you
something can I tell you something
though this is funny by I'm like a good
mimic so and I I hit another ball I got
I got a piece of another Ball but it
doesn't matter but um but so so I I was
watching I was like a while back I just
scrolled through Instagram and there was
a major league pitching coach who was
saying to everybody he was going you
guys don't have to pull back when you
hit you go from here just to there just
there to there and you'll save time I
never forgot it so I was watching I was
like all right I'll just I'm not you
know I don't play [__] baseball but I
went I play enough tennis I can see the
ball now I was afraid because some of
those balls I got I got a whole video
where you see
like when they start going you can't get
your batt around in time not a chance
it's just like too fast I'm I'm too old
I'm an old man it's the hardest thing to
do in sports oh my God a fast you're
what
just so but I but again I enough enough
tennis so I can see the ball and so I
all I did is I'm thinking and once I got
over the fear because my heart was
racing I didn't want to get hit and and
they're [__] and I just went I just
went I'm just gonna I just did this I
just got that and I got it see I would
have preferred to see them where they
can only throw 99 or higher and you try
to hit it well they that would been a
better video they did and you can see me
Swinging I have that video see I would
have liked 10 cuts of those going I have
that I have that on video and then you
hit one I have that that's that is what
happened by the way that's not that was
after about seven pitches that would
have made that video way more viral I
took some Cuts Like showing how hard it
is going I have I should that's what I
should post it looks yeah that looks Sil
yeah that's a shitty video cuz then you
think they're taking it easy but if it
would been like
you and then ding that' been dope yes I
have it I have that video I I'll get
that because uh that's what I should
post right it's better yeah it's late
now but yeah [__] um because that's what
was happening I was Swinging with in
Earnest and at one point I felt like it
got a little close to me and I ran away
think about that dude yeah I heard the
Dodgers was trying to decide between you
and Otani well so this is interesting
because there was a scout there and he
said how old are you and I said I'm I'm
in my 50s he goes [__] and I go what he
goes it's
just I got to make some calls and then
because back I didn't hear backhead
weird I didn't hear May they're just
mulling it over well they're mulling it
because because my hand ey coordinate as
you know is did I mention this off the
charts and so I feel like if I can hit
two M I got a piece of two right because
we can't your liability out in the field
I I was you know what for the first it's
been a long time I was catching balls in
my mitt and throwing no you're not going
to be a catcher right cuz that's the
toughest job going to be C Sports catch
so short stop probably not yeah maybe
first base you're a little undiz I got a
I got a tail piece on me but when you
talk about baseball players they're all
ass and leg especially when they come
from the Dominican and there was a
gentleman from Kuba there Kuba and he
was cheed up baba he wasn't just cheeked
up really he wasn't just cheeked up I'd
like to get my peepers on this pH he had
the longest legs I was looking at how
long his legs were God you like you're a
pig and [__] around he he had he had uh
he was eban he was quite quite quite uh
tall probably let's give him 63
63 uh obviously you can see never lifted
a weight in his life but had that crazy
V and just all that thaty Minaj oh all
all ass and legs and and you would have
been right there with me shoulder toosh
shoulder because I kid you not I could
just see the outline of a [__]
Panther's tail that makes sense a real
swan a black Swan's neck a plantain just
a dark plantain hanging out the front
just sit cuz the only place for that to
sit that thick Cuban cigar out the front
it can only sit like a loafer like dark
loafer he's bunched up inoss his [__]
cuz there's no you can't do much about
that you got to wear it AC along your
leg or a bunch I can only imagine you
got you can you can curl it up like a
like a snail's tail but that's not
comfortable guy didn't talk to him BB he
was quiet cuz he doesn't have to say
much he doesn't have to move much or say
much when you're working with that whole
situation good for you man good weekend
then good weekend good weekend good
weekend let me pee real quick good you
had to pee over that that work your
bladder get your bladder going oh man
this is another episode of huge black
dicks because I don't I gotta I gotta
stop do I stop I talk about male body
way too much
everybody oh God I'm sure a lot of
people are like I can't again with this
I can't but I'm just saying a lot of fun
it's not your fault you're great yeah
yeah I was a my friend said if you can
touch that ball he trains them he's the
their training goes if you can touch the
ball I give you
$1,000 got a piece of two balls off two
different pitchers they were roasting
the guy I got a hit off of they were
roasting not a hit but a foul ball
roasting him on a group chat they were
like oh you got but then you know all I
want to do is stand at that plate and
try to get try to C get those hits now
because I can see the ball I can see the
ball I how fast was he pitching they
were pitching the 98 miles hour in some
cases some of the ones I missed were
coming by me at 98 wow 97 98 yeah when
was the last time you went to a batting
cage uh uh when I was 12 when I was 12
the last time I was in Arizona I hit two
years ago in I hit a 65 mph pitch
seriously from a machine yeah but
remember I play so much tennis and the
ball comes fast so I can I I'm I'm very
used to seeing and timing with a racket
now ball that size so I told him I was
watching the ball and I was watching
them pitch and I was like I was I was
very afraid to get in front of the on
the plate I was because it's terrifying
but once you get over that fear I can
see the ball I the my problem isn't
seeing my isn't hand ey coordination
it's I can't get my bat around in time
with technique I don't know how to I
don't know how to swing a bat I I don't
play baseball but I'm a good mimic and I
can watch and I can kind of like fake it
you know
so yeah yeah that was impressive bro
that was super impressive yeah and I got
the the other one was even better
there's another one yeah he that was a
faster pitch and I actually caught a
piece of that nice and so I was like you
owe me $2,000 but they were all they
were all like they all made a you know a
racket because it was funny but uh the
the two things I'll be talking about for
a very long time is the fact that I got
two I got a piece of two major league
balls in a real training camp and my
testosterone's 97 without any help
without any help so that's super I'm I'm
I'm not a I'm not a bad athlete
everybody all right just know that you
have any plans for your birthday since
it's coming up really soon no it
depresses me I feel like I'm too old why
I don't want to be 57 but I had the best
show of my life this Saturday this early
show the best show yeah I think this
Saturday that was the best show of my
life awesome I like what I'm doing and I
like what I'm writing and I think it's
coming together so you're in your Prime
man I hope so it feels like
it certainly feels that way spiritually
and intellectually and artistically we
see you had a birthday coming up your
son is um your son is uh clearly if you
if you he's on steroid yeah if you had
to predict if you had a 7-year-old that
was on all the steroids that would be
your son his neck his traps dude he on
that Primal diet miniu thicker yeah he's
much more oh yeah when I I was not that
thick when I was a kid I asked him
earlier his favorite food was you know
he's a kid I me he looked straight at me
and
steak so beautiful he's got like he got
like jaw muscles sometimes the filets
are a little high priced at Whole Food
so I got to get the New York strip and
when last time I got the New York strip
he found out wouldn't eat it even though
you can make it taste the same so now if
they have New York or it's you know
whatever a different cut than filet I
just lie to him and go look it's filet
oh yeah was buddy's house we had his
buddy house yesterday and they were
cooking steaks I said what'd you get he
goes ah we get we got some ribe eyes on
there sh sh you tell him it's filet he
go really he won't eat anything else
he's like what oh my God he's he likes
it lean dude it's all he knows you know
I messed up great fet I messed up I
don't like filet I like myself in New
York strip I don't know why fet just
feel all day because Rogan took us to
Eddie V's again I had that filet with
the um oh my mouth is watering that
filet with the horseradish crust on
top man it's nice does Rogan need
anywhere but EDS I don't think think so
oh we ran to Brian Redban had dinner
with us I've seing Brian forever love
him yeah AB Comedy Club crushing it that
dude is crush it ran to Tony hinchcliff
ATS crushing it looks great yeah looks
great shredded he's shredded right now
selling out Arenas God it's incredible
crushing out there man yeah man that's
the that's where it's all happening and
you and I are going to be at the some
news soon okay you'll have some what
we'll have news soon okay we'll have
news soon I'm at the vul in this Friday
Saturday
but fireing the kid live might be back
there very shortly very shortly might we
do a residency out there in Austin
aren't we uh I'd like to do a residency
out there in Austin I think that would
be a great thing for us and I think it'd
be a lot of fun and I think there's some
big guest lined up yep we'll have some
news soon so let's see did you talk to
our boy about
that Mr Joseph yep yep we're good baby
we'll figure it out but we're going to
do a red and sea out in Austin we'll
have some news soon mhm mhm I'm so chin
would need to come we should probably
feel chin on the
dates I mean I'm always we going to get
ourselves an Airbnb what are we going to
do uh Hotel cuz we're not I can't be
there Monday nights okay yeah we don't
need to stay together right I feel like
we do no I don't want to no I want to
stay with you two grown man a man you in
the
shower what are you doing nah you want
to talk are you are you in bed nah bro
no I'm I'm going get word on my uh uh
truck I'll I'll also be able to post a
video I talk to Insurance I'll be post a
video but I I'll have news Wednesday
okay so the the insurance is we don't
know yet little up here we do know oh
you do I do know so they they they're
they're good good baby okay all right
how's the old arm they're going to cut
it off the AR dude Wolverine my arms
healed yeah there you go and went the
hot tub clear everything up um I hear
good things about peptides when you have
some I don't know about a cut but you
know there's like there's all of us
everybody wants to take something right
now I I what happened was I got a paper
cut so I took all the P PES are good but
not for a cut if you if had like
ligament Dam did you have peptides when
you were fighting or is that a new thing
new thing peptides weren't out I wish
they were still illegal to take they are
peptides are illegal yes former steroids
man is it yeah HGH steroid does the same
you can't take peptides no frown upon
yeah what do you got Jen now that I play
baseball I might start because I want to
get my bats speed up no baseball you
should have talked about peptides around
there those boys know a thing or two
about they all get no they all get
tested and they don't look like they're
doing hey I know I know it's fun you
made some new friends okay I get it hey
look at
me no Sports more involved in PS than
MLB is that right yeah but they don't
look the same the way they used to back
in the day right when they were like
jacked out of their minds they were
taking de and everything else you've
seen Aaron judge bring up bring up Aaron
buba he's 67 240 lbs yeah those
Dominicans are uh some of them are
giants and they're deadlifting so
Washington this got deadlift 600 for
reps I got a buddy who's close with the
Dodgers you know Otani was deciding
between Toronto and LA and he was going
to go to Toronto but he has a 40-man
Entourage that he brings with him well
that's way
so the it's tough to get all those
people into Canada so he thought La
where is Aaron judge from that's he's
American baby yeah that's a big fella
right there that's not him that'd be
Stanton there so that's not him but
that's okay where where on the right
that's not a no that's that's Aaron
judge that's not Aaron judge that's
Stant says it but I don't know that's
not Aaron judge that's Stanton okay yeah
Stanton Stanton too that's Aaron judge
the guy on the muscle and fitness would
be Stanton oh okay yeah Aaron judge is
not a small guy he looks like he play
football basketball okay uh-huh uh-huh
Superstar yeah and uh you think I'm not
saying no I'm not I'm not making any PD
AC you just say guys are smaller I'm
like no no no no they're all big every
one of those pitchers was 6'4 I mean
they were all huge yeah pitches got
taller but when you see the oh my God
282 lbs jeez well some of those guys I
saw out there were like from California
yeah some of those guys out there I saw
who were pitching were that big they
they were just I was like it's crazy the
the guy um what's his name Frankie uh oh
[__] but you know Otani 6'4 now Otani is
a giant ja he's 6'4 they're all big
Staten who was on there is 66 to 45 like
they're huge man so one of the pitchers
he's from Cuba you love this uh our boy
Kevin Bay Kevin trains him Kevin's the
best so Kevin's training him and he's
from Cuba right now he had never lifted
weights he just showed up as a 270lb 6'
5 in Cuban guy who happens to throw 102
mph yeah and uh and he started
weightlifting and he's like what is this
and he was deadlifting
762 lbs sir just like yep just and you
see it's not like he's cut he's just big
and just stick just
thick said he's just T is not small I
think he's like
205 dude how long take a little break
dude let's take a freaking break take a
break how long has it been since you
changed your spark bugs it's been a hot
second but I know where you're going
with this you're talking about O'Reilly
and I've been at O'Reilly this past week
seven times for real I've been O'Reilly
seven times yeah cuz uh we're putting a
a Whipple supercharger on the lightning
and there's an O'Reilly up the street
dude O'Reilly had the OEM belt that I
needed they had the valves I needed the
valve stems they need everything for
complete willwood brake kit dude in
stock if they don't have it on the
showroom floor they have it in the back
there the the people that work there are
knowledgeable they look it up they give
you the right part I'm tell you whatever
you need o're has you idium spark plugs
you can get those too cuz when's the
last time you change your spark plugs
wiper blades right now you wish you had
them cuz raining like cats and dogs out
here in La all you got to do is go to
oilly auto.com for spark plugs wiper
blades so much more they have the save
now with Do-it right deals in store at
O'Reilly Auto Parts all right that's
oilly auto.com look it comes when it
comes down to the best Nets on the
planet they're macademia Nets when it
comes down to the healthiest oil it's
probably Omega 7s that are only found in
macadamia nuts macademia nuts are super
expensive unless you've corner of the
market unless you work with over 90
farmers in South Africa unless you
support that local economy and unless
you have House of macademia in your
corner so head over to partner. houseof
macademia
dotf I'm going to say it again head over
to partner. houseof macadamias Doc TFK
now subscribe to your favorite bundle
get free snack bars every time with 15%
off the whole order plus certain bundles
come with bonus goodies like free
macademia milk and free shipping change
up your macademia subscription at any
stage no strings attached pause or
cancel anytime House of
macademia and he what is did he sign
some crazy thing like it was like hold
on let me call it's it's the report from
three weeks ago no $700 million or
something crazy 8 is it 800 I think it
was seven but you know he's only getting
2 million a year he's deferring all of
it cuz of taxes oh so at the end of the
10e mark he gets the most majority of
his money for tax purposes it's
brilliant so he's like 2 million and cap
space it's
great wow
700 to the wall he's already got you
know oh CU annual s jumped to $68
million so he's doing okay dude he is
Tom Cruz in Japan I mean he's has so
many endorsements out there but out
there it's nut here here is's massive
he's a batter and a pitcher yes which is
in what league in
the now now hold on let's go back to
football did you get any football in of
course okay and uh my Buffalo Bills loss
yeah that was a that was a bummer man
bummer and then Detroit Sam Fran my two
favorite teams right now yep San Fran
for mcaffrey Detroit for the coach I
love them I think I think it's be San
Fran versus Baltimore you do you do yep
because I I I think that Kansas City is
that strange shoe in that that
Baltimore's so damn good Baltimore's so
good and they got to go to Baltimore
they're playing so well right now yeah
but I don't know there's something about
K Kelsey and and uh our boy Mahomes
they're they're don't say our boy right
because you forgot who he was yeah we
don't know him but Kelsey and Mahomes
that's a you know that whole team
there's something about it
man wow General General General I like
it though I like the effort man I but I
would I would put my money in a weird
way on on them all right let's back you
want a bet who are you saying it's going
to be well I'll take Baltimore over casy
you will yeah you'll take Baltimore over
Casey yeah I'm going to take that bet
and then th bucks yeah I'll bet you
$1,000 Baltimore overc Casey straight up
Yep this is good yeah it is and then do
you want to bet uh on uh Niners Detroit
I I like both those teams I think ners
going to beat them really Niners are so
good but you
know I'm gonna go with Detroit I think
it's gonna be Detroit Kansas City and I
think Kansas City's going to win the
Super
Bowl uh I'm going to I think it's going
to be I'm going put
$25,000 I think it's going to be
Baltimore versus the San Francisco 49ers
and I will probably take Baltimore to
win it all I'm going for I don't like I
don't like Baltimore I'm not a fan of
Baltimore but I I like that LE playing
in that game what do you got
Jen so what do you think you know
football oh yeah oh I've said from the
beginning it's going to be Niners Raven
Super Bowl damn 100% who do you think
wins that game it's a tough one I go
with the ners really do is is Debo
healthy is Debo healthy he'll be all
right I think the last they said he came
out of the locker room without pads on
that wasn't great but I think he's okay
what what happened what he what did he
hurt a dirt shoulder
yeah I don't know man this is Caff can
run I was watching so I I'm watching the
bills uh I'm watching I'm on YouTube CU
I bought that pack I'm watching the
bills Kansas City and it was just I'm
like just watching this insane game and
then I
watch Tony who's off sides and I watch
Kelsey do that amazing thing where he
laterals back and they win the game and
I'm like they're going to the freaking
you know they're just they're moving on
it was the game from you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then I keep seeing like
there's another game on be like you
going to watch the game I go the games
are
over
God damn it Boomer stuffff yeah Boomer
stuff what do you at Jen before um
you're talking about bets you owe me
either 50 bucks or lunch remember drus
Su I'll take you to lunch tomorrow where
there's a spot over here that we always
we bet on WE bet on Strickland new place
no you and I both had we both picked
Strickland yeah all right first
one friend of the show guys right
Natasha I love Natasha funny lady uh was
performing here in LA and went on after
Bert ker and decided to copy him a
little bit and I guess everybody loved
it God bless
[Music]
her this next person stage is abely one
of the funniest comedians I know in the
world I am I am jealous of her husband
because he gets to live with her she is
that hilarious ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen isn't she married to mosha yes
take that off for a second what is
Natasha up to lately stand
up she takes her shirt off
yes oh D just tits out what yes she's
copying Bert is the crowd going
[Applause]
wild oh my
God
that's holy [__]
holy
[__] good for
Natasha she's a badass hilarious badass
that's
[Applause]
cool that's great that's both you that's
great that's great I'm impressed I'm
impressed that's really she's a badass
yep she's funny too man yep funny and
adorable and all that so if the boys can
do it why can't the girls yeah
I mean it makes sense right I'd assume
the crowd would rather see her shirt off
than BS but I'm just throwing that out
there I don't want to be sexist probably
probably Dave Chappelle's calling out
cat gu saying that he's trying to take
food out of you know their brother's
mouths and oh he said no shade at the
white boys yeah no he shaded white boys
shade Rogan and the entire crew that
wasn't shade to Rogan though s Rogan
puts onfunny guys on it's only white
guys I didn't interpret it as shade what
part of the game [__] up another uh
paper Chappelle says he didn't say
anything about any of these white boys
what part of the game FS up another
Ninja's
paper legit Point legit point is this
clip part of the game is this he only he
didn't say anything about white boys
white and is one of the best in the game
that's right draw all ugly pictures of
[Applause]
us yeah whites pull each other down too
don't get it twisted white Comics pull
each each other down too yeah are these
guys
friends do you guys know that I don't
know how close they are I mean everyone
respects cat I would suggest that cat
probably is a hard person to be friends
with in terms of how we would Define
friends because he seems rather
unpredictable unhinged yeah yeah I'd
love to hear him on Rogan though ran
threw out the line too I was like let's
do it yeah that came out of nowhere too
the the shanon sharp thing how it blew
up that fast million out of nowhere like
Cat Williams I thought yeah I didn't
know he could do those numbers he's
interesting very who knows what's real
what's not but it's interesting it's fun
to talk about y a little politics for
you guys the santis dropping out and now
sense makes sense nobody's going to be
Trump he's going to be your Republican I
don't know why I didn't drop out earlier
maybe just got to give it a go you got
to give it a go cuz you're doing it
you're setting yourself up for next in
the next four years I mean him and Trump
as VP yeah bro you think that's the play
that might be yep cuz it's crazy right
they go from like talking mad [__]
on UFC Kamal ha is what she said about
Biden when they're running said believed
that he probably raped that girl yeah
horrendous and then that's his V that's
politics that that he his me too things
just went away didn't it real quick cuz
he's on the right side how interesting
meaning he's on the left I there's his
mother the woman's mother Tara Reed's
mother called into Larry King and talked
about that senator who assaulted her
daughter you know she didn't she didn't
say politics they don't they don't take
anything personal like they when this
debates they light each other up and
then they're I assume it's over and then
they're back having sharing cookies and
milk in the back like they don't they
get this part of the game yep they say
the nastiest stuff and then after like
that was good man it's
crazy all right uh this is also about
Trump I saw this on Rogan's post um
there was like some red marks guess
what's up no I bet uh I bet it's
psorisis bet he burned his hand on a
stove H or he was playing golf they were
saying it could be potentially playing
golf but then they're also saying uh
there was people reporting that it could
be cus or some other crazy stuff right
heres but it turns there's the the
Insiders are saying it was just like a
paper cut and then it just smudged over
and then later on in the day definitely
not paper cut that does but later on in
the day um could beis CU so stressed out
that's what happened to me they edited
that they clean can you go back to the
other picture up there he looks very
very strained there he looks older and
that's he yeah he when you see him in
interviews you're like man yeah I'm sure
it's taking his toll on him even though
he's a tough son of a [__] that has to
eat you up he's going through [__] it
has to be the most hated man in America
the most loved most hated yes that's
right there's no nobody's just like ah
he's all right it's either visceral hate
pure love there's no middle ground I
wonder if he would have done it um in
hindsight yeah I I would love to ask him
that too I know he's a narcissist and
you know you want to be the PO most
powerful man on Earth but if he knew he
had to get dragged through all this junk
well there [__] kids too I know would
you still do it was the juice worth the
squeeze yeah I would say no but he might
be like yeah I don't give a [__] he's
just built different you know B
different yeah it's crazy yes
oh did I see you Chris and Sammy the
bull saw a picture you deia and Sammy
the bull yeah Sammy the bull came how's
he doing he's great we had a we had a uh
they're doing a still killing guys or no
no they're doing a whole uh he's got
Heavy Hitters for a TV show that he's
doing about about his life it's pretty
wild i' watch that oh it's it's sick
so go back to go back to that did Chris
like him yeah Chris was like Chris has
never met anybody like that but he he
was telling us jokes in the in the green
room with all these people funny as [__]
give him a hot five he's very smart give
him a hot five I I would actually uh
Colorado man accused of killing
decapitating woman had severed hand in
his pocket during arrest yeah
interesting is that a seped hand in your
pocket yeah I wonder what happened so
he's a security guard and the best part
was is his roommate was saying like he
asked me to go to the car with him and
he was trying to move this quote big
object out of the way and he had a ton
of blood on him and asked if he could
use like a power washer to clean himself
off like so he asked his roommate to
resolve the $1,000 off your debt and
help him Dig a 10-ft
Hole uh wait um help him move a big
object oh that guy that guy reported
this guy sounds like a real smart guy uh
and a what a [__] nightmare what did
do we know if he knew the
woman that I don't know but
uh he said I had the hand in my jacket
for two
days so witness who reported him to
police borrow his car that night and
returned it J say he left the gun and
phone in the car he later alleged that
changes story oh it's a prostitute so he
picked up uh prostitute on January 8th
she prly asked for money for a sexual
act he said no he he allegedly told the
police he dropped the the victim off
around 2 2:
a.m. okay
uhhuh oh wait that hand Martinez repo
had cuts on his hands which he claimed
came from dogs then he said the cuts
came from picking up dogs feces near
rocks some evil [__] out there
additionally detectives located blood
inside Martinez vehicle yeah he screwed
you mean he didn't take he didn't get
away with it you mean the dog picking up
dog poop rocks didn't work with the cops
your plan was to put the blanket over
the body huh sounds great what else you
got Jen what a oh dick I hope he gets so
only fans reach out to Snoop Dog and
asked if he'd be willing to show his you
know what and said you could reportedly
make about 100 million but his wife said
no what would your guys' ladies say
about this I would say I wouldn't do
it million mil my wife like get that
dick out no I mean I know but like like
I just got to make 100 Mil and that's it
you're part of some you're part of some
[__] I don't know no right 100 Mil I
would do it not so not porn right it's
just like showing your got to show this
thing ramp confusing yeah I don't know
well you know I I think there's more I
would need a GU I need a guarantee
you're not making 100 Mil you're going
to be doing a I need a guarantee where
like all you do is send a picture and
we'll give you 100 Mil I I would do it
like send the money in
a there's some weird stuff going on
there are people who do this and snoop's
so set I don't think they need to go for
somebody a little lower on the status
yeah damn how about the Pawn Stars Sund
d horrible fent another another overdose
is that terrible I love that horrible
horrible and his brothers uh posted a
picture of him and uh his dead brother
as a baby it's tragic man awful dude
only
39 that's so sad oh man that is it has
to be tough as a dad because if you
didn't have the success if you didn't
sign up for this Fame does he still die
you know probably Bubba though I don't
know if it's the fame this this [__]
gets a hold of people ah fame's tough T
them and you have money and resources
and who knows if the guy got connected
it's terrible look at that you just you
just you and I both have kids and unless
you have kids you don't understand how
unim imaginable it is like honestly is
that the same kid though this no
different kids different different
moms tough that's his
youngest tough dude horrible so
tragic love that show man that guy's
great too he knows his [__] too
terrible here's another terrible I don't
want to watch that I I mean they don't
show anything but you can definitely
hear him I don't want to hear it no I
hope he's okay it says Bahama shark
attack child screams in chilling footage
get him out of the water yeah the shark
probably was like I'm going to take a
little bite out of this this is a
popular place too it's at Atlanta place
in the bahas shks they bite you know
they're they're they're big and the
sharks are swimming with the people or
is the kid supposed to be in there this
shark expert was saying like a 6ft shark
can take a much bigger stronger bite out
of you than any big dog well they they
they a shark like the [__] [__] yeah but
a lot of people are like ah it's just a
shark no hell no it's going to bite n
shark I will never get the fascination
with like let's go to a place like the
Bahamas and get in a crappy tank and
just hang out with some sharks I don't
get it yeah no I wouldn't do that I'm
down to do being a cage while it great
white and CH the waters what's crazy to
me is that woman who was killed on a on
a she was on a what is it a paddle board
she was standing on a paddle board and
that that tiger shark killed her killed
her got her like came out of the water
what about it just surprising to me why
shark doing shark [__] yeah but no they
usually wouldn't see that as food they'd
see it as a piece of wood they see
something moving yeah man it's a tiger
shark that don't give a did you see the
footage of the blood on the board and
the tiger shark still there around the
board I haven't seen any oh
dude crazy my algorithm doesn't pick
that stuff damn have you guys been
peddle boarding on in the ocean it's a
really nice experience right but I'm not
going to go anymore after all these
attacks yeah I did in Hawaii it's so
much fun yeah he's saying he'd get in a
cage the cage is different though CU
you're protected for the most part how
much do you trust that cage well the guy
sometimes they do come in again on my on
my Instagram I'm literally I don't
really I'm I'm on the plane and I'm
getting ready to do something and I'm
looking at the post I did and then I I
skim down and then somehow I get I'm
scrolling and there's the uncut version
of that Australian s
where that great white the guy was
fishing the great white you see this
great white's tail and all this blood
and it was a massive shark massive and
my question is you're doing this open
air swimming in the wildest part of the
ocean like it's a matter of time bro in
Australia that you know great w are
everywh you're always doing it every day
I mean I'm sorry man I'm not doing that
[__] no say well you're more likely to
die in a car crash it's like yeah yeah
but I have water all the time but if
you're there every day what's the odds
when someone's in shark INF Fest Waters
Every Morning open ocean like what are
those odds we don't get those odds
correct and all they do is go no you're
more likely to die in driving here I get
that but what are the odds if I'm
swimming every single morning in shark
infested wat for Miles where the odds Ro
deep water we don't get that no no is
that it Jin you go with that all right
cool that was fun there you go all right
kids this Thursday keep on trucking tour
kicks off in Nashville one night only
January 25th at zany and then I skip on
over to Austin Texas back in Austin I'm
a regular now in Texas Austin Texas the
stepmother ship the Vulcan TH or Friday
Saturday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday January 26th 27th get your
freaking tickets at thick boy.com right
I'm going to be in Louisville Comedy
Club boy they still haven't changed that
date uh that's amazing Let me refresh
February 19 February uh did they change
it see yeah okay there you go it's not
March one two or maybe it is it's March
1 March 2 okay uh Louisville Comedy Club
I'll be there and then uh Bricktown
Comedy Club March 8 and uh the new
Bricktown too in Tulsa yeah I'm excited
iard that's a great club and all right
kids that's it love you we're out